I wanted this to be good I really did
but that being said I still think you'll
enjoy this episode of things you missed
stick around to the end of this video if
you want to hear about all the
connections to other Stephen King novels
the new 2019 adaptation of Pet Sematary
takes a lot of inspiration from the 1989
version of the film which is kind of
surprising to me when we covered the
original you can watch that things you
missed episode right here I talked about
the foreshadowing where gage is seen
crashing the red toy truck the 2019 gage
offers a similar clue in the car when
the family drives to the house he
smashes a toy truck into the carrying
case that they used to transport their
cat Church as they arrive in Ludlow
Lewis drives through the downtown area
and I'm obviously using that term
lightly but this isn't something that's
in the first movie and it's not really
in the book but it does kind of resemble
the downtown Ludlow scene in Pet
Sematary - it may be that both films are
basing this off of a real-life location
but I wasn't able to find one in a quick
Google search Lewis is seen in a Cape
Cod shirt and the reason for that is
that the Crede family is now from Boston
as opposed to Chicago this may seem like
a popular choice now but we'll see who
wins the World Series in Super Bowl this
year when they first arrive at their new
property Lewis makes an offhand comment
about the great and terrible this line
also comes up again when Ellie mentions
it during her killing spree at the end
of the movie but what is the great and
terrible this is a line from the book
that becomes a motif and is repeated
throughout the term originates when
Rachael's helping nurse her dying sister
Zelda as a child where she pronounces
the classic Wizard of Oz character as oz
the great and terrible it serves as a
label for Zelda's horrible behavior
towards the family in her final days and
it constantly pops into Louis's head as
a representation of his demons during
the story the last section of the book
is titled I was the great and terrible
before Lewis starts his job at the
University of Maine infirmary he
mentions that his previous occupation
was working the graveyard shift at the
emergency room a little nod to Stephen
King short story
graveyard shift which also became a
movie
is the new horror from the mind of
Stephen King graveyard shift he also
mentions that they had to treat for
bloody noses on his first day
this phenomenon is further explained in
the book basically the university
students would come in with minor issues
in order to get out of their exams back
at the house Rachel and Ellie explore
their new property when they come across
the funeral procession of kids wearing
animal masks the drumbeat played by
these children as they make their way to
the pet cemetery is very tribal and the
ritualistic practices are very
reminiscent of a Native American
practice like perhaps the burial
practices of the Micmac Indians who
buried their dead in the area beyond the
pet cemetery Ellie would later go back
and check out the pet cemetery for
herself and when she does there's a
little picture frame in the bottom right
corner with a photo of a pair it's a
reference to a grave that Lewis notices
in the book for a pet named Polynesia
who died in 1953 the headstone for
Trixie appears almost exactly as it is
described in the book right down to the
misspelled kilt on the highway and only
forgoing the date of death there's
another pet grave marker that King
described in the book who appears in the
movie and that is bitter in the book
biffer is a cocker spaniel belonging to
the dessler's family and biffer was run
down by a dumpster truck one year before
Lewis brings his family to Maine but in
this movie biffer is jut krandalls
childhood dog who he revived in the
Mi'kmaq grounds before finally laying
him and to rest in the pet cemetery
judge dog in the book is named spot so
I'm not really sure why these things
were switched much like a lot of things
in this movie one more detail on the
scene Ellie's shirt has a butterfly
design on it there are a few examples of
butterfly imagery associated with Ellie
there's a picture of a butterfly framed
above the family during dinner
and she also draws a picture of a
butterfly and be later on this drawing
connects to the scene where Ellie wears
the butterfly shirt well she gets stung
by a bee while trying to climb the
deadfall that leads to the Mi'kmaq
burial grounds but why was she drawn
towards the burial grounds the answer
comes later on when judge is explaining
why he showed Louis the burial ground
despite his own dog coming back evil he
tells Louis that you just find the
sweetest-smelling reasons to go back to
the burial ground
so if Ellie represents a butterfly I
think she's attracted to the
sweet-smelling flower that is the
Mi'kmaq
when Ellie returns from the pet cemetery
she has some questions for her father
about death which brings up an argument
between lewis and rachel about how it
should be explained to their children
this trigger is a flashback to rachel's
childhood where she had to tend to her
sister zelda in the 1989 movie Zelda's
wardrobe matches that of this creepy
painting seen in the house in this 2019
film she wears the same gown as the
Grady twins from the shining a patient
named Victor Pascal was brought into
Lewis at the University after being
struck by a car Lewis has no chance to
save him and after his death the lights
flicker as he comes back to give Lewis a
warning the flickering lights seem to be
a side effect of the appearance of
ghosts
because when Pascale comes back later to
give Lewis a second warning the lights
flicker in Lewis's basement Ellie goes
over to bring some cookies to judge
Crandall who they still don't really
know at that point so I'm kind of
surprised that Rachel would let her go
inside of this guy's house alone but
luckily for Ellie this is the pet
cemetery movie not Romeo Lacoste the
YouTube channel
but there are some noteworthy details in
Judds house he's a hunter in this movie
and he's even got the typical deer mount
on his wall you have to wonder if he
became a hunter to try to get revenge on
the Wendigo deity that revives corpses
in the mcmac grounds and possessed his
dog biffer the one to go legends tell of
a creature with a stag's head so maybe
Jud was searching for the one to go when
he acquired this mount there are a
couple of other references to the
Wendigo we hear its call at the very
beginning of the movie
[Music]
and as Jud exits the forest for the
first time you hear the bugs go crazy I
think this has something to do with the
Wendigos influence after burying church
Jed explains the curse of the one to go
to Lois and how he first found out about
it from a boy named Stan EB and finally
Lois researches the mythos in this book
on northeastern tries I did a whole
video on the 400 year history of the one
to go in Pet Sematary which you can
watch right here or just look for a link
in the description at the end of this
video
Jed also tells Elly about his wife Norma
who got sick and passed away years ago
Norma is actually a character who
doesn't pass away until three months
into the novel Lewis saves her life when
she had a heart attack on Halloween
which is part of the reason that judge
feels he has to help Lewis revive his
daughters cats as kind of a thank-you of
sorts but in both movie adaptations now
Norma's already dead before the story
begins at least she is mentioned in the
2019 film and when Judd faces zombie
Ellie and the final act she seems to
take the form of Norma momentarily to
mess with Jo Ellie's favorite pastime is
dancing she can be seen doing the dance
of the Sugar Plum Fairy from the ballet
The Nutcracker The Nutcracker is a
ballet about a toy Nutcracker that comes
to life and battles with the queen of
mice in the story the family's cat is
brought back to life and acquires a
habit of killing small animals like mice
and birds although the only example I
think we see in this film is church
bringing home a dead bird
Victor Pascal tries to give another
warning to Lewis by taking him to the
pet cemetery and showing him the border
that should not be broken at the end of
the sequence a hand comes out of the
ground and grabs him this could be a
reference to the iconic scene from
Carrie or at the very least a clue that
Lewis is going to the land beyond the
pet cemetery and that could put him in
danger of being attacked by zombies
the next major event comes on Halloween
Elly is dressed as a witch and she
jokingly threatens to put a spell on
Judd to which he replies you already
have this could be a subtle reference to
the fact that the wendi-go already cast
it didn't influence on Judd all those
years ago when he buried his dog in fact
later that night when they go to bury
church Judd takes Lewis to the pet
cemetery and unlike the book and the
original movie it looks like Judds
original intention is to let Lewis bury
Church in the pet cemetery but if you
watch the scene that there's a
noticeable moment where something gets
Judds attention and he stares off at the
dead fall in the direction of the
Kersh burial ground it's like I
mentioned earlier the Wendigo traps him
with the sweet smell of the burial
ground and there's nothing you can do to
resist it Ellie goes trick-or-treating
with two other kids dressed as ghosts
which may represent Pascal in church the
two deaths that have occurred up to that
point when Judd tells Lewis about his
cat being killed he mentions it was one
of those of Rinku trucks a Rinku is a
trucking company that's most prominently
seen in the Pet Sematary novel where
they run down church engage and they
also make smaller appearances and some
other Stephen King works when they're
going to bury church Louis notices this
spiral image on the trees when they're
later researching the burial ground they
see more imagery of this spiral what
does this mean in King's novel the
spiral serves as a symbol of the bridge
between the world of the living and the
Gulf when Lewis visits gages grave one
night he finds himself thinking about
the layout of the pet cemetery and how
it mimics the ancient religious symbols
seen on the tombs of Pharaohs the
bearers of venetian kings cave walls
Stonehenge and Bibles then he shocks
himself by looking down and realizing
that he has drawn the spiral with his
finger in the dirt subconsciously when
he goes back to the burial grounds to
Ribery gage he notices that the rock
hands knocked over by the revived
corpses who are escaping their tombs
come together to form a gigantic spiral
once seen from above so Lewis and Judd
successfully bury Church and the next
night Church returns from the dead and
goes back to his room Rachel tells Lewis
good thing you're not a vet which is
another little nod to the 1991 film Pet
Sematary - which is not based off of any
of Stephen King's writing but features a
main character whose event Lewis goes to
confront Jud who explains everything
about the Wendigo they look at a map
where you can spot that they're in close
proximity to little gods swamp the area
in between the pet cemetery and the
Mi'kmaq burial ground in a book where
Lewis has his encounter with the one to
go the one to go isn't shown in either
movie but there is a moment where he
hears a branch snap and looks into the
distance where based on his reaction it
is implied that something moved he also
looks up old headlines from the Ludlow
Tribune that report on the incident with
Hanratty the bull this is another small
Easter egg pointing to events in the
novel where a man named Zack McGovern
tried to revive his prized bull using
the Mi'kmaq burial ground and the bull
came back is one of the most evil
creatures ever to be revived it would
charge at small animals people and even
swaying in the breeze it caused a ton of
damage around town nearly destroying
itself before being put back down
there's also a brief glimpse at a
headline about Timmy Bader Minh the son
of Bill Bader Minh
Timmy died in World War two and his
grief-stricken father tried to bring him
back by burying him in the Indian burial
ground if you've seen the original movie
you know a little bit more about the
story but it's only mentioned in passing
in this new one so with Church being
back Ellie tries to comb his fur but she
has a hard time exclaiming Church you're
so sticky there's something gross well
you shouldn't let Shane Dawson babysit
your cat with you but in all seriousness
the service is a setup for when Lewis
tries to comb Ellie's hair in the bath
after her death and discovers the
staples still in the back of her head
that were used to hold her together for
the funeral but before we get to that I
want to highlight the scene where Lewis
notices Ellie drawing pictures I already
mentioned the significance of the
butterfly and be drawing but there are
two other drawings that may be
significant Ellie's other drawing is a
picture of what appears to be a whale in
front of a rainbow now this one I admit
this could be a stretch but I'm just
gonna say it and let you decide how
intentional it actually was so the
zombie version of Allie would later use
the form of Zelda as a psychological
attack on Rachel and The Legend of Zelda
video game franchise has three flying
Leviathan creatures that resemble whales
known as Levias the wind fish and OSHA's
again I'm not saying this was an
intentional connection but it seems like
a strange thing for a child to draw the
other picture is drawn by gage and it
appears as a disturbing image of a
monster which is implied to be a warning
about the Wendigo I did a video where I
talked about how Ellie uses the shine to
try to warn her father about the dangers
that await them but since Ellie engages
roles are switched for some reason in
this movie I think this confirms that
gage is now the resident psychic he's
also the one who later has the dream
about pass cow that later sends Rachel
rushing back to Maine to try to stop
Lewis from reburying their daughter so
if you thought Rachel taking a
cross-country flight based on the dream
of a child was a bit much in this movie
she's going back based on the dream of a
two-year-old maybe that's why they
switch to Rachel's family to being from
Chicago to Boston in this one it's a bit
of a shorter trip and perhaps more
believable but before we get to that
part there's a scare with Church
possibly attacking engage in his crib
which leads Louis to release the cat
just before Ellie's ninth birth
I party they invite some of their
friends from Boston to this party and
one of them can be overheard in the
background muttering something about a
big st. Bernard with rabies this is a
reference to another Stephen King book
Cujo about a st. Bernard dog who gets
bit by a bat and turns into a dangerous
beast this reference also exists in
different forms in both the novel and
the 80s movie but there's also a direct
reference to the 80s movie itself and
that the truck driver is listening to a
song called Sheena is a punk rocker and
by the Ramones when he runs over gage
in the new movie he gets distracted by a
phone call from a contact named scheana
right before he hits Ellie Ellie goes
into the coffin wearing white as a
symbol for her purity and childlike
innocence when she later returns as a
zombie she changes into the dirty
clothes that she wore during the
accident signifying that she's now
tainted by the evil influence of the
Windigo when Louis returns from
relocating his daughter's burial place
to the Mi'kmaq grounds I spotted a
height measurement chart for kids in the
Creed's house this might be shown to
make us think of the heights that Ellie
will never reach having met an early
death or it could just be about the fact
that Louis had to dig her up the maximum
height on the chart goes up to 6 feet
actually 6 feet isn't down there it's
more like right here but 6 feet is
typically the depth at which coffins are
buried when Louis wakes up the next day
he hears Ellie once again dancing to the
sugarplum fairy song from The Nutcracker
but this time her gracefulness is gone
and she's just wrecking the house and
basically being a brat meanwhile the
rest of the family is staying with
Rachel's dad in Boston as I mentioned
earlier gage has the shine and he senses
something is wrong a lot of characters
throughout Stephen King's entire body of
work have shining moments but this one
is particularly emphasized by the fact
that gage wakes up from his nap and
starts streaming Pascal over and over in
the same manner that Danny yells out
Redrum in the shining
[Music]
so this dream causes Rachel to drive
back to Maine with gage where she gets
stuck in traffic on the highway on the
side of the road there's a sign saying
that they're 20 miles from the exit for
Derry which is the fictional town in
Stephen King's books most notably the
setting of its insomnia and dreamcatcher
the rest of the movie plays out very
similarly to the original Ellie brings a
scalpel to a gunfight and then somehow
wins and then returns to her own house
trying to kill Rachel at this point in
the movie you can spot a painting of the
Emerald City from The Wizard of Oz
another low-key reference to Oz the
great and terrible it makes sense to see
the painting at this point in the movie
because Oz represents the evil entities
that all the characters are starting to
become when Rachel makes it home and
sees that Lewis has used this cursed
magic to bring back their daughter
she disagrees with the decision because
she realizes that it's not natural
Lewis has his own reason for doing it
then he argues let God take his own care
this is a reference to something Ellie
says near the beginning of the book
after first discovering the pet cemetery
and learning about death the movie ends
with Lewis getting impaled by a cross
and gage being the only one left with
his three zombie family members four if
we count Church coming for him
I think it's implied that he doesn't
survive which to me all right let me
just put my opinion just this one it's
less scary than letting the remaining
child actually survive because when Elie
survives in the original she's gonna be
stuck with all of those scarring
memories and also living with her guy
grandparents which is definitely not a
plus so the credits roll but there's one
more thing that you might have missed
actually I nearly did miss this myself
because they turned off the audio to
begin a Q&A with the casting directors
at my screening but somehow I noticed
this in the credits a cover of Pet
Sematary by the Ramones from a band
called star crawler which is cool
because it's the same end credit music
that Mary Lambert had in her adaptation
of Pet Sematary but also kind of defeats
the purpose because the whole reason
that she got the Ramones was as a
reference to blitzkrieg bop the most
well-known and probably most expensive
to licensed Ramones song which was stuck
in Louis's head throughout the entire
novel that's one of the many things I
talked about in my things you missed
episode on the original Pet Sematary
film so click on the video on the left
if you want to see that remember to
subscribe to see ZZZ world for new
Horrors every week bring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both get buried
in a pet cemetery